[Music]
hey glad to be with you on what is
obviously uh a heavy day just wanted to
issue a quick note here before I go into
the show um obviously our hearts go out
to the people the hundreds of people at
the time of uh this broadcast um who
have been senselessly killed um in
Israel uh this weekend and uh with that
being said I want to set up some some
parameters here there's a reason that I
haven't tweeted a whole lot about this
because all of this can't be fit into
what used to be 140 characters now with
X I get that it's extended but it still
requires a little more than that I think
that everyone can agree or let's set
some guardrails everyone can agree that
the senseless targeting and killing of
innocent people is evil and needs to be
condemned as evil and the people who
celebrate this are completely evil to be
clear and I think that uh my personal
opinion I shouldn't say I think is that
Israel is an important democracy in that
area of the world um and certainly an
ally to the United States when you're
talking about uh morally and uh Intel
but I want to be clear about a couple of
things here because this is a time where
we can have a discussion that matters
you can acknowledge all of those things
and also hold the opinion and we'll get
into these differences here that maybe
the United States has created such a
quagmire over there that not being
involved um with any kind of foreign
intervention would be in the best
interest of our country and Israel I'm
not saying that people here are hold
that position but it is a valid position
to take that is being expressed out
there I ask that you listen to those
people before you dismiss them as
anti-semitic just to be clear and it's
also a period of time where we can
acknowledge the United States's
screw-ups and being at the very least
complicit in helping to arm terrorist
organizations not just Hamas across the
globe and that doesn't mean that you're
anti-American or anti-military we need
to be able to talk about these issues
and discuss this tragedy today without
right away throwing people under labels
and believe me I'm not one of those guys
who hates labels all the time in all
facets but there are rational positions
to take uh today as we look at the
senseless violence because the violence
is senseless it's it's not senseless
actually it's evil but you can look at
evil and have different rational answers
in how to deal with it so if nothing
else today I just ask that before you
pop off and comment listen there are
different points of view in the studio
and certainly with you watching also on
like this that are incredibly heavy and
I know you think hey this is not going
to be a comedy heavy show I assure you
uh that that is incorrect and if you are
easily offended today is not a day for
you let's go to a rewind
[Music]
intro
Rock sck rabbis oh boy Rock them sck
rabbis boom right in the Kipper press
the buttons move the joystick thingies
knock his Kipper to the floor right in
the P You're the
winner he's just like me best two out of
three dad you're my best friend roam
sakam rabbis by Milton
Bradon remember none of this is possible
without you join the fight and sign up
for mug club today at
louderwithcrowder.com mugclub for $89
annually join the fight at
louderwithcrowder.com mugclub
[Music]
[Applause]
today I
know
[Music]
yeah that's delicious nice I'm trying to
be grateful for the little things little
things like
Bigalow huh it's a TBR right now someone
out there is like it has I don't know
was it PF or bpas don't use that te I
have no idea I don't care a lot of
fluoride too not just in my T but in my
tea all
right glad to be with you today I I
would say I'd rather be with you under
happier circumstances but uh um let me
ask you a question right off the bat
here do you think that there's a
contradiction in uh supporting Israel
and being against the proxy war in
Ukraine comment
below now I don't necessarily think so
but I I I see a lot of opinions going
around I think that the the numbers
really matter here it's a numbers game
it's all numbers games kidss today so
we're going to be talking about that
today but there's also a lot going on
here in the United States let's give
them the rundown uh I don't know if you
know this but former vice president bid
did a flipflop on the border wall so
we'll be talking about that uh Hamas has
decided of course you know to attack
Israel we'll discuss that we'll be
playing hate symbol or not on mug club
and uh trans lesbians are just normal
lesbians no they're not no because is it
International lesbians day or is it
national lesbians Day thought it was
International International I don't know
it's got to be International it can't
just be National there's also like
lesbian there's like lesbian and trans
visibility day which is completely
unnecessary because we can
tell we always see you yes and we are
going to what was that that was remember
Avatar when James Cameron someone pulled
this clip for later where he was at the
premiere and he
said and the lady said what he said that
is na'vi for I see you and I had to
watch through my fingers and I still
shrunk into my body C still cringy all
right so that and more but it's actually
the birthday of Captain Morgan how are
you today sir am doing well thank you
very
much
hey you do not look a day past 54 thank
you very much I really do appreciate
that how are you doing I didn't get to
ask good good good not your birthday
right it's my birthday it's your
birthday that's right I got you nothing
and you'll like
it and when you hear this you know who
it is he brings a smile to our faces uh
also um gratitude for his service Friday
October 13th he will be at Messi Jess in
Aberdine Washington what's that messy
Jess you don't want to know Gerald what
Mr Josh firin how are you sir Nam mam
mamasa that in which in na'vi means I
ripped you off for billions of dollars
that's what she said gosh let us know
when they find that clip he's like a
na'vi means I see you James Cameron I
just I just is that like the premiere or
something my fist involuntarily clenched
I was more mad about that than Hamas
which says I get it I need to work on me
about you
yeah get your priority
straight can we just can we just
paraglide can we paraglide James Cameron
into Gaza and just you know let the
cards fall where they I think so I think
we can all right so before we move on to
any of that uh you know this is just for
a pallet cleanse thanks to only fans o f
as some of you know it that's not how I
Know
It of I know it as my private browser
just kidding dude this man this man let
me just set the up for you beforehand
because it's going to be our 2023 simp
of the year he had an only fans girl's
name minky that's her real name tattooed
on his wrist 20 minutes after meeting
her she offered to pay for the tattoo
but he insisted he insisted they should
have at least gone Dutch and uh the
prize is he get a he gets a lifetime
subscription to her only fans account
hey you want to know why Western
Civilization is collapsing that brings
us to the 2023 simp of the
[Music]
Year Shut Up And Take My
Money
he's wearing
[Music]
eyeliner that's a Serbian or something
that's not an
American he doesn't know what he's
getting
[Music]
tattooed oh subscription
sent Shut Up And Take My
Money I don't understand this I don't
understand why what do you think is
going to happen do you think this woman
is well you know what so when you think
she going to tell your kids like
interesting story how your father and I
met it's a totally different how he
didn't want to pay me he didn't want to
pay me but he wanted to see me and he
got a tattoo she's not even pretty
everything is fake he's not even going
to get to date her you met her in person
and her response is I'll give you a free
subscription yeah I'll give you a free
subscription it it it comes along as a
bonus with the restraining order yes
exactly can I have your phone number no
no can I take you out to dinner probably
not guys can you explain to me what this
is if you are I didn't even fully like
only fans I guess I thought it was like
you paid for an umbrella membership and
you got access to everything you were
it's just hitting the tip jar for that
individual lady I have no idea and I'm
happy to say that I don't know if you
know this but there are like plenty of
free naked ladies out there in the wild
oh yeah yeah they're out there in locker
rooms at the Y and you can just walk in
I don't know if you knew that just claim
to be a woman you get the range naked
lady put on a wig and they're cool free
range organic farm
backed they get at least 134 square m of
space to roam you can tell the
difference with the eggs
now the brown school bus school bus
orange the Yol all right I apologize by
the way uh as we discussed it because
you never know what happens with YouTube
sometimes they really like Hamas so uh
if at any point today you see
this head on over to uh Rumble I don't
know why I almost said Target
what it was in my head I had to stop
myself from saying Target why would you
make that statement I have no idea head
on over to
Target bathing suit yeah they have the
Bull Terrier with the eye thing all
right he died tragic so according to the
UN speaking of Israel trans lesbians are
lesbians which you know here's the thing
if it is just a statement of fact that's
like you don't need to make you don't
need to make it right it's hey it's it's
International lesbian day there are
lesbians people go yeah I
know what when you have to say there are
men who are lesbians people
go all right I guess that's where we are
now so remember this is do we have the
tweet from uh from uh the UN say
remember trans lesbians are lesbians too
they should have used the word also what
trans lesbians are lesbians also bring
it back up I want to read it because I
don't have it here it says let's uplift
and honor every expression of love and
identity oh every happy International
lesbian Day by the way don't you just
love how they bring it all together love
and identity because it used to be right
if you implied that there were some type
they said well hold on a second you
can't choose your sexuality right that's
one of those things because they were
angry with Christians saying like well
we're talking about choosing the action
of homosexuality whether you agree with
that or not but then they go but you can
choose uh not only your gender and then
choose your sexuality uh when you become
a woman to be a lesbian just just just
keep your
penis it's more fun that way with again
the naked ladies in the wild it's more
fun if you have a penis that's my whole
point right but it is a point no no no
but they they mostly keep their penis a
lot of have it still hold Josh I'm
trying to work this out of my
head which one is a
man who identifies as a woman but likely
statistically has kept his penis because
they don't commit yeah who likes women
it is man well I tell you isn't that
just normal well I tell you what that
that is for the lesbian who just has
daddy issues she calls that uh the bonus
prize she gets the best of all worlds
and remember if you don't accept
transgender individuals as lesbians
you're a trans phobe if you're sis and
you won't take trans folks you're trans
phobe now if that made you mad maybe
it's your prejudices that you need to
probe no matter the reasons you've got
you're reducing us to when we dis
robe and that kind of thinking Ain
sophisticated it's more like a microbes
where human beings not sex organs
lesbians I'm talking to you I I really
love her rendition of Amish Paradise as
well weird G yanker dick
yeah the problem is not that you're a
trans lesbian the problem is that uh
you're uh you're
talentless kind ug they give such a free
hey look if you're being here's my
advice just to kids out there if you're
being bullied in school today just so
you know just claim your trans for a
little bit you can always change change
it back just claim it yeah yeah
bullying's done it's one of those
non-committal things you can just go
back and they will make you homecoming
queen yes exactly hey by the way if
there's no Janice Ian here what really
want to piss you off we have the Cameron
clip now okay James Cameron really
quickly big screen as the na'vi say well
Nati kameha I see you
no but he actually did it at a
Premiere as well all the rest of the
people they all did it back oh my gosh
all right anyways you can comment below
because it helps with the algorithm hit
the like button but how do you celebrate
International lesbian day and by the way
that's a bad question there are no wrong
answers I too watch M Halland drive now
let's talk
about I like trans lesbian girlfriend
she comes with her own dildo it's great
built in buil built in yeah
I okay so we're going to talk about this
tomorrow because I will say sometimes
intern issues distract from issues that
are important at home uh as well and all
of these are important and by the way
Israel is one of the few issues
internationally that really does have
something to do with our national
security interest wherever you line up
and we're going to give you a chance to
comment along in the chat today but
tomorrow we are going to do um a more
lengthy segment uh as well as by the way
a Japanese study tomorrow that you know
that Co Omron the more recent V that it
is absolutely irrefutably bioengineered
in the lab yeah doesn't occur in nature
and no one talked about this study so
we'll talk about that tomorrow but uh
last week the former Vice President
Biden uh his administration they made a
major reversal we'll get into it
tomorrow as to why saying that they
would unlock funding for
a a border wall and the Biden
Administration is giving the go-ahead
for a new border wall in South Texas the
president had to wave 26 federal laws to
okay the wall this despite promising not
to build another foot of the wall if
elected 26 of their own laws wave 26
laws I don't know that I do that now the
answer as to why hey you're a big reason
for that they do ultimately at some
point have to answer to you when there's
enough of a ground sell so tomorrow
we'll get into that more um did you have
well I was going to say it actually will
tie into this story a little bit there
are a lot of fears with all of the
tensions right now with is pro
Palestinian movement Pro Israelis
movement and people that have been
coming through that southern border so
we we'll see how that ties directly into
what we can maybe expect by people you
mean terrorists ah yes I do women and
children are seeking Refuge yes they
make up % they identify as military age
men though yes exactly well it's look
it's hard it's hard it's International
terrorist lesbians day so that's
true those haircuts are fire though dude
they're actual fire yes yeah they if
you're a Christian in a cage
so all right so just to recap this in
case you've been living under a rock
obviously Friday began Friday Hamas
launched uh a terrorist attack on Israel
from Gaza now what I'm going to do today
is give you a little bit of a kind of a
recap if you haven't watched our
previous installments on Israel the
history of Israel of Hamas of the Gaza
Strip all of these things and then we'll
get into our involvement here today and
by the way if you're not a member please
consider signing up joining mug Club
lc.com mug club uh you get this show you
get Nick toal every day you'll get an
additional hour of show every day Alex
Jones on Friday you get Brian Ken show
the Hodge twins they have their show now
we're we're adding every single uh every
single week so we're not able to have
these conversations um without you guys
because sponsors won't want anything to
do with this and I don't blame them wait
a second we're on the same show as
Rockham sakam rabbis click
yeah so Friday from Gaza Hamas a
terrorist organization launched uh
launched a terrorist attack on Israel
including um these aren't just missiles
and by the way this is the most uh I
believe deadly attack in about half a
century it also involved murdering and
kidnapping and in case you are squeamish
we're not going to be showing any of the
actual deaths here just to let you know
because you can find that everywhere
right now researching this is terrible
but they've kidnapped hundreds um of
Israelis also um potentially you know
Americans here's a recap Palestinian
militants from the armed group Hamas
launched a surprise coordinated attack
on Israel by land sea and air on
Saturday morning with hundreds killed
the attack is the largest and deadliest
in years and prompted in Israeli
declaration of
war
now before well you know there's a lot
of misinformation out there so before we
move on um when reached for comment um
Rashida T said quote my nipples could
cut
glass Lis Faron said I won't be needing
Viagra tonight but that's giving him an
out he's a blueo man oh he's a blue man
new sponsor yeah I yeah
no Faron so just to give you an idea
it's over 700 at the time of
broadcasting it is 10:30 Eastern right
now over 700 Israelis have been killed
that would be the equivalent to by the
way 24,000 Americans for context as a
percentage of the population um number's
growing I saw so jel C Rosenberg lives
there is there right now and I think he
updated the number to about 800 I'm not
sure where he's getting it from but we
expect that number to just keep climbing
the number's likely somewhere between
700 and a thous low thousand something
right now uh and by the way this is
taking place on the 50th anniversary of
the yam kapor War
also a Jewish Festival uh simat Torah is
a thing that goes on it's a holiday that
they celebrate I'm not Jewish so I'm not
as familiar with it they have a lot of
holidays had a lot of them in September
we know that well because had many you
know our Jewish employees just
disappeared angry because he wasn't
eating I thought it was the Rapture and
we were
wrong thank so this happened Israel uh
prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu
declared war on Hamas officially and
that's a big deal saying we will turn
all the places in which Hamas is based
all the places h m is hiding in acting
from into
Rubble um and the IDF warned locals uh
by the way to be clear as they started
attacking so this is a big difference
that I think you guys need to know
wherever you line up and if you think
there's too much involvement with the
United States and Israel um and I
understand where people are coming from
to I understand hey where are these
people going to go gener generationally
you know who live in Gaza you know
they've been indoctrinated so I I
understand that perspective but there's
a stark contrast between you know Fort
Knight paragliding into Israel to kill
women and children and the IDF actually
warning people in Gaza to leave before
they issue counter strikes yeah I
believe several hundred people were
actually killed at that music festival
jez so and then they were going door too
through neighborhoods basically just
trying to find women and children and
Men whoever they could find and pulling
people out of their cars on the streets
so like this is not at military targets
no this wasn't just a warning they've
actually said there are two war crimes
because they were they also did launch
some missiles but from civilian Target
from civilian locations into civilian
locations so they were putting their own
people at risk which is right Hamas
while targeting innocent women and
children in Israel Israel issued
warnings to the people who have been
used by Hamas just to be clear it's kind
of difference between Pearl Harbor and
even though it was way more damaging
right when you're talking about dropping
the big one when you're talking about
dropping the a bomb we dropped Leaf list
to let people know hey get out of these
cities there's a difference in the
spirit there just to be clear so let me
recap this also what's going on okay you
probably have a few questions what led
to this attack is what we hear a lot um
what role did the United States have
there's a lot of misinformation going
around from both sides on Twitter sorry
x uh and why is Israel important or are
they to the United States in the first
place we're going to try and answer all
of this uh and more it requires a little
bit of of History to start this off so
uh Gerald you can kind of help me with
this Israel you know we'll go back to
1948 okay so the formation of Israel
modern Israel because there's a whole
bunch of we're not going to go into Old
Testament all that right now right
modern Israel as you know it after World
War II the UN not necessarily known for
being a fan of Israel decided the Jewish
people needed their own land to call
home the reason for that was I don't
know if you know this uh Jews got the
short end of the stick a little bit in
World War II in World War II it was a
bad deal it was a bad No Deal said
Arnold in Raw Deal so May 14th 1948 in
47 the Arabs they rejected the UN
partition of land the Jews accepted and
then uh really through 1948 Israel they
ended up declaring their independence
there was a war between them the
immedately immediately in 1948 they're
like oh you're here War yeah exactly and
I also understand that people saying oh
okay it displaced but again the Jews
needed somewhere to go and I believe it
was uh was it Helen Thomas who said they
should go back to they should go back to
Germany and Poland ah I believe we have
that they should go back someone can
bring that up where she said from her
wheelchair Like Larry she's like female
Larry Flint they should go back to where
they were being exterminated
so that stabilized that war to give you
an idea uh somewhere around 1949 okay
this brings us to something that's
pretty important if you're not aware of
this because a l lot of you will see
maps of Israel and you'll see maps of
Palestine which by the way is not an
actual country and they weren't wanted
by neighboring Arab Nations just to be
clear in 1967 there was the six- day war
so I think this is important because you
need to understand how land has changed
after that war because it brings us to
the current conflict so after a series
of uh provocations by these Arab states
and also them plotting to wipe Israel
off the face of the map uh there was
Egypt Syria and Jordan I Believe um
Israel decided that okay it was time to
preemptively uh attack at that point
they were increasing threats they were
saying how do we know that they were
going to wipe out Israel they said we're
going to wipe out
Israel how do we know that they meant it
because they said we really mean it just
to be clear they said oh you really mean
it this time yes ah not kidding folks
right they're like
not they invaded Jerusalem yeah
[Music]
foots
got control over Golden Heights the West
Bank there was a SI Peninsula here's a
map exact after that war is that the map
yeah leave that up that's the map after
the war which Israel won just to be
clear because a lot of people saying
Israel keeps expanding territory because
they're going by months it's kind of
like watching the stock market but if
you go by day these fluctuations seem
radical if you go by you know the
totality the overall length of time you
understand that overall the market wins
out which is why a Strategic investment
uh approach is simply to buy the whole
anyways the point is the point is if you
just look at it from a day trading
perspective you won't understand the
context so that is the map after Israel
won the war again I think that matters
because when you win you typically reap
The Spoils of War right we have a clip
here is what they've given up since that
win in that
map there's no audio there's no audio
okay okay look that's Israel territory
there you go sorry our bad see it being
given up being given up being given up
mhm smaller smaller smaller smaller
smaller okay but that's but but if you
just give us land you'll have peace
exactly every single time exactly so
before we get into the United States and
before we get into forign a it is
important to understand that look Jews
needed a place to go okay this was an
international agreement at that point in
time and then there was a war because
people tried to wipe him off face the m
they won the war and then they gave up
lots and lots and lots and lots of land
I get that that doesn't solve the issue
generationally of kids who grow up now
and hate Jews in Gaza I understand that
but that context matters brings us to
1973 the yam kapore War okay they were
caught by surprise um the Jews and if
you know anything they don't like being
surprised Jews typically don't like
surprises what no like no they got to
give me a heart attack Egypt and Syria
all the
Exterminating again so it was Egypt
Syria okay there you go uh and the war
led to a peace treaty between Egypt
Israel 1979 okay Israel gave back Sinai
to Egypt at that point okay this bring a
lot there it's not a whole lot but you
know what they also I mean there's some
good doctors at Cedar siai So Different
siai yeah I know but the name is still
there yes 2005 this brings us to sort of
what happened in in Gaza there was this
disengagement under um prime minister I
believe at that at that point in time
was it sh shiron shiron Ariel
Chiron yes no well maybe maybe could be
anything goes today uh Israel pulled out
of the Gaza Strip that's important
that's a big deal they pulled out of the
Gaza Strip for that period of time
whether you like Israel or not yeah yeah
they pulled out completely so if you
want to blame them for what's going on
in Gaza right now you're going to have a
really hard time because there's
somebody else in line that took power
the year after that yes and by the way
Israel was somewhat involved yes that's
true in bringing Hamas to power as sort
of an anti-coalition against their
current government so that is a valid
criticism to make I understand that it's
more complicated than that 20 uh
2006 Hamas then uh they were elected uh
democratically as leadership in Gaza so
a lot of times people say Hamas is not
palestin oh hold on a second you elected
them you elected them yeah so yes they
are in their own Charter they said that
the day of judgment will arrive when
Muslims kill all the Jews and that all
of what is Israel is Muslim land
eradication of the Jews as part of their
Charter and a Hamas official just to be
clear in 2022 so up until recently that
was their Charter when they were elected
mammood alahar said the entire 510
million square kilm of planet Earth will
come under assist where there is no
Injustice no oppression no Zionism no
treacherous Christianity so a lot of the
time people wonder well a second Jews
Christians why is there this Alliance
we're not just talking about being
grafted in by the faith but you do have
to understand what these other people
the opposition to Israel these
terrorists also want they want no
Christians either they want no Jew they
really really want no Jews but they also
want no Christians but they really want
no yeah absolutely well Israel is the
little Satan America is the great Satan
like we are seen as the bigger enemy for
them to conquer but Israel is the
closest enemy that they can reach out in
touch yes right so this this is if for
people who are out there saying that
these people don't actually believe that
that it's not actually part of their
belief system you misunderstand them
fundamentally it is in their religious
doctrine that is why when we say hey
economics and they go yeah we'll take
that it's the religious part they don't
care yeah like their entire eschatology
is built off of this enti system is
built off of this and not every single
person who ascribes to that Faith
believes everything that they're belie
believing as well I I understand that
oligarch governments do what understand
even if you are an atheist even if you
don't believe you use a spaghetti
monster great I took religion 101 in
college to um if you believe it doesn't
matter these people meaning these
governments that have been elected these
terrorist organizations they do and it's
very hard to fight a strong belief in
something even if the belief is in
something evil with the lack of a belief
that's how vacuums are created and those
vacuums those voids get filled usually
with radical ideology so these
governments believe that they are doing
Allah's work in eliminating Jews and
Christians now you can also say yep I
get that they believe that but they have
no chance at actually touching the
United States certainly Hamas that would
be true but that brings us to this
International Coalition and again please
comment below as we go along uh we'll
take your chat today we may not even
play hate symbol or not because I think
there will be a lot of discussion here
today and I and I will say this as
someone if you go back through my
history obviously been a strong
supporter of Israel but I don't believe
that someone who says we should not be
involved uh in fun Israel or any of
these nations is anti-Semitic just to be
clear I do not believe that I think that
that is a lazy argument and I know
plenty of people who support Israel who
don't believe that we should be funding
all of these proxy wars who are they're
the furthest thing from anti-semitic I
just want to be clear about that because
that is one thing where I think
conservatives get this wrong don't throw
that out there it's lazy um this brings
us to what is
happening and and the former vice
president administration's involvement
in contrast to the Trump uh the Trump
approach hey let me ask you this before
I move on yeah you know people always
talk about Donald Trump and they say
okay the economy sure like now it's kind
of acknowledged the economy was better
under Donald Trump but remember everyone
was saying he has no foreign policy
experience yeah he's gonna he's going to
start World War II right that was the
big refrain now if you look at the polls
it's kind of irrefutable that even
liberals a vast a huge portion of
Americans think that they were better
off economically here under from under
uh president Trump have we reached that
point with foreign policy I think so
Afghanistan got to be right this you had
two the two biggest peace treaties
Israel had ever signed with anyone in
the Middle East and here we are today oh
but they like us come on now yeah and
we're look I hate to say this this just
the beginning we've got a little bit
longer to go of this administration's
policies taking effect but this is the
third thing to happen right yeah Donald
Trump goes in and just unites the Arab
world in ways that we didn't think with
the Israelis by the way that we didn't
even think were possible then he
fulfills his obligation to move what was
it our our the United States Embassy to
Jerusalem did that and like he did so
many positive things and you didn't have
Russia invading Ukraine and you well you
had you had them still you owning Crimea
from 2014 but not under his watch didn't
anything else he didn't have the
Afghanistan problem that he would have
created with his plan to pull out and
you didn't have this stuff happening
right like it I I don't understand
people's argument against Donald Trump's
foreign policy wins and you and by the
way Josh thank you for your service over
there in the Middle East you did spend
some time with some Israeli soldiers
right yeah yeah they uh well I don't
know much about their culture but very
it was mostly just the female soldiers
they're cute they're real cute and the
outfits highlight that yeah yeah they
should put it in a brochure yeah they do
they should put it in a br they should
put their long Cur hair rary and white
Christmas g hi wish I was back in the
Army you're like oh you're wearing the
corset and the that's actually what they
do good-look women they are them and the
Egyptians and they have their uniforms
are just right I know it's true I don't
sometimes
sometimes a little less walking like an
Egyptian a little more mounting people
which is not something I support but
people say it so do they say that they
do say it I don't know who said it I
think it was division lot of people that
brings us uh to and we'll do some claim
and truths that are uh kind of
circulating right now what is happening
under the watch of former Vice President
Biden good evening we begin tonight with
one of America's closest allies attacked
and now at War the scenes this morning
across Israel were chaotic un
precedented and terrifying the
Palestinian militant group Hamas
choosing a Jewish holiday to launch an
attack on and into Israel there was the
barrage of rockets into Israel but also
incursions by militants these were the
scenes of Kamas Fighters storming across
the border marauding through the streets
of Israel can we also grab by the way
guys uh uh Mission Control grab the clip
of them paragliding in like fortnite
that was really disturbing it looks like
right now isra oh it was just on CNN
that they are um striking in in lebanes
territory so I'm not sure look this is
the point it affects all of us my
favorite restaurants are Lebanese really
we all have to make sacrific their point
does this does this mean how L guys is
closed today God I hope not by the way I
love how they screw you with the red
sauce like red sauce like how hot is it
it's red sauce
and very your face will melt off you'll
be back all right so let's go through
some claims here that you are hearing
versus the truth okay here's a claim
that I'm going out there in defense of
Biden that Aid to Gaza uh was never
going to be used to support Hamas right
this is something that we were told
quite a bit yes 100% because people were
saying again back then hold on a second
Aid to Gaza that sounds like you might
be sending some Aid to terrce and he
said no no I was not going to terrorist
like but that's kind of who
runs that's their elected leadership
only government if you're if you're
sending it to them and it's not going to
who are you sending it to exactly we're
going to send money to the Coca-Cola
Corporation but none of it will be used
for Coke it no well yeah but you you're
sending it to Coca yes we're sending it
to Coca-Cola absolutely but so that is
co use for other things they don't do
other things actually they do they have
I don't know it's Nabisco they have Dan
yeah Dan tastes like wet Nickles F so
this brings us to the truth okay uh
former Vice President Biden knew the
risks at that point started sending Aid
to Gaza Anyway by the way about 360
million oh that's doll just to be clear
in 2021 Biden restarted Aid to the pal I
in Gaza and the West Bank and let's
contrast that with Donald Trump he'd cut
off $200 million in a and he cited
hamas's control of Gaza as justification
there you go he looked at the government
and said Hamas is in charge I'm not
going to send them money it was a pretty
simple like it was pretty simple what a
bad guy in other words it's a super
complex answer from I'm going to send
I'm going to send some money over there
but it's not going to go to the people
who run it well where is it going to go
it's going to go to the place where the
under the people who run it oh you know
the thing yeah you know the thing
where's B Where's Donald Trump like hold
on a second is that is that is that the
place is still run by piece of of
us I don't want to give money to piece
of of us 200 million oh new rules
gone it just cut right to it it's so
easy yes thank you president Trump and
Biden and the White House said that the
aid was intended to be used exclusively
for humanitarian con uh concerns and by
the way just so you know at that point
in time as we did if you question that
you're line dogf face pony soldier I
don't know what that means I don't think
you can just use that every time dog
face Pony Soldiers the handle for his
only fans
account I believe he was speaking na'vi
Yes means I my
pants again so here's also some cold
hard truth the USA is it's it's it's
also co-mingled it's hard to find the
numbers with all other kinds of Aid and
funding sketchy including AIDS probably
they said AIDS yeah I would like that
like the un education programs in
Palestine right they they glorify
Islamic martydom they promote
anti-Semitism uh Hamas has used un run
schools to hide weapons and not to
mention this Aid has directly been used
to pay terrorists uh salaries and
pensions that's the one that really
sticks in my CW that is true is when
they say it's not going to go to fund
terrorism except for some of their
salaries and pensions is that hourly or
is that like
uh deal this guy gave in them faster
than the UAW neg
go they got to retire at some point we
want to terrorize 32 hours a week do you
know how hard it is to be a terrorist we
want a 30h hour work week but to be paid
for for look look the problem is there's
no loyalty in terrorism anymore okay the
terrorist dream is dead we had a deal
there is no white picket bomb
no by the way the referenes are all
available okay we put the link in I used
say sidebar but we put the link in the
description go to ler.com yes directly
to fun Sal ands to terrs so even if you
really really really don't like Israel
some people out there can we all agree
that we shouldn't be sending any money
like I know what you're saying what's
the appropriate dollar amount to
terrorist salaries and pensions uhuh
uhhuh I'm an extremist I believe it
should be zero we should be charging
them send them invoice yeah exactly you
send them an invoice they ow us for the
introduction to our bullets yes it's a
finders fee bang
now the UN the UN is just they're
they're completely they are useless
feckless they're about about as useful
as you know we have we've had this year
we have them on retainer again our
resident X-Men and we wanted Charles
Xavier but we we ended up with his
brother Chad jeez you can just be
sitting there doing absolutely nothing
and your name goes through like 70
computers a day and you're right it's a
typo Orwell's here now he's living large
we have no names no
names this counter isn't up to
code coffee thank you
[Applause]
he really is useless isn't he straight
up and by the way while we just checked
in with people at work that moment in
time I guess just the UN just what out
to calling for peace and tweeted it out
do we have the tweet I think so right
just in do you can you read it for me
Joe the horrified by what is happening
and we call for a truce so they call for
a truce ah H bre I know it's on HS now
but you know I I love it that they call
for a truce when Israel is basically
taking care of business now listen I I'm
not a warmonger I've been accused of
being a warmonger for simply pointing
out that when somebody comes in and
attacks I don't know first a music
festival where there's absolutely no
armed people 260 people at least killed
in that and actually kidnapped and raped
there there's footage of people bleeding
the girl that they pulled out of the
back of that van was bleeding from her
ass you want to take a look at that and
tell me that if that happened in the
United States that you wouldn't want to
at least strike back at the people who
did it so when they're going out and
taking care of business after being
sucker punched this is the counter Punch
coming back you're saying whoa whoa whoa
whoa how about saying that before the
Sucker Punch is thrown yep and by the
way before you preemptively say oh hold
a second with the occupation what
there's a big difference between land
and uh anal rape there's a big
difference between land and going in and
Del L kidnapping torturing and killing
children there is no doubt about that by
the way that that is what is going on
and I don't mean collateral damage
because you also point to Israel and say
well H they've killed that happens in
all wars and it's absolutely tragic and
it's why I'm very generally anti-war but
there's a huge difference between all
right out of our own security interest
we are going to have control over this
specific area which at one point wasn't
under our control but you just couldn't
play nicely and chasing down innocent
women and children and sodomizing them
and putting them in cages and torturing
them can we can we agree there's no
moral equivalency there definitely no
moral equivalency and by the way we do
have the hand glider not the hand
gliders they're not hand gliders parag
this was what actually happened yeah
they're just so you can see let's bring
it
[Music]
up he's come flying in there were there
was more than one by the way I was
hoping to get caught on that antenna
yeah guys I'm sure you can find the one
where they see a bunch of them coming in
from the sky yday you have two clips do
you have the second one is that one the
one that has multi the one yeah yeah
yeah we and by the way just so you know
we've had to sift through things and
make sure that we can run clips that
aren't showing the actual murder of
people we'll tell you about it tell you
about those clips but uh this I think is
still yeah it's safe to show where you
see what it looked like in the
sky yeah this is at the music festival
they zoom in and there's like just dots
on the horizon
[Music]
basically it's like fortnite of hate
yeah so let's go to another claim that
you're hearing right now because this
matters the United States involvement
claim that there there's no proof Iran
uh was involved secretary blinkin made
this claim on Sunday in this specific
instance uh we have not yet seen uh
evidence that Iran directed or was
behind this particular attack okay
here's the truth
jez Iran was absolutely
involved not kind of maybe sort of there
is no doubt Iran provides a $100 million
annually to Hamas celebrated hamas's
attack calling it a proud
operation the supreme leader and I don't
typically call him supreme leader yeah
but his it's a self-title it's a
self-title yeah I call him
leader of Iran uh Ayatollah Ki uh he
also there Ayatollah K he's the one by
the way who can issue a fatwa uh also
tweeted God willing the cancer of the
usurper Zionist regime will be
eradicated at the hands of the
Palestinian people and the resistance
forces throughout the region um and even
Elon Musk address had to address that
tweet condemned it but left it up which
back in the day the ayatolla was still
still allowed up but Donald Trump was
banned Donald Trump was banned so at
least there's some consistency there I
don't like that he wants the eradication
of Jews but I guess we respect his right
to say it I think you have to see that
stuff sometimes to know that evil really
is out there you can't be like oh they
want the eradication of Jews and be like
uh well I don't know it's right there
I'm glad he highlighted honestly I'm
glad I'm glad Elon Musk replied to it
because he's got one of the largest
followings on on X and getting it out
for people to see and just so you know
by the way in Cas well that's just one
person it's not the there's a difference
between the people of Iran and that well
here's a clip from what it looked like
in
Tron oh wait sorry that was New York
York
[Applause]
here's that looks like more than just a
few bad apples that really does it
almost looks like they had to shut down
traffic like they were shooting Vanilla
Sky in Times Square now according to uh
a Wall Street Journal report as well
known we can't confirm this but it does
seem to be uh accepted right now at this
moment in time again it's about 953
Central so 10:53 uh Eastern on Monday
Iran did help coordinate the attack
proactively and helped plan it so this
is a quote it says Iranian security
officials helped plan hamas's Saturday
surprise attack on Israel and gave the
green light for the assault at a meeting
in Beirut last Monday officers of Iran's
Islamic revolutionary guard Corps had
worked with Hamas since August to devise
the air Land and Sea incursions just to
be clear so $100 million a year goes
there's no doubt about that just to that
is something that is irrefutable goes
from Iran to Hamas and now there are
reports detailed reports with receipts
that they also helped plan this specific
attack by the way do me a favor research
out there when when secretary blinkin
went out and said what he said I believe
that was on Sunday that he said that was
that Wall Street Journal article out
already because I don't know if he has
better access access to uh intelligence
than reading the Wall Street Journal but
I'm assuming that he does and so if they
got it vetted it printed it I'm assuming
he might be able to get that information
beforehand and then maybe not go out and
lie good point at least have access to
you know X's trending topics I mean that
would help Google Trends I do something
might help B back paper whatever it
takes I don't know comment comment below
if you think that we're being
unreasonable I don't here's another
claim that we're talking about Iran this
brings us to um again America's
involvement and I'm certainly not saying
that America wanted this to happen but
you do have to accept the fact that we
are so intertwined with Bad actors
across the globe right now at some point
we're going to need to scale it all back
and we definitely have played a role in
this not in targeting innocent people
but in unfortunately in one way or
another supporting Nations that are evil
let's be honest they're founded upon
evil the Iranian is founded upon evil
their government is evil Hamas is evil
okay you cannot give money to the
Iranians or even allow money to be used
by the Iranian allow it to go to Hamas
and then condemn it so funds this is
what they're claiming right funds that
the United States gave to Iran were also
so Iran had nothing to do with the
attack and certainly not funds from the
United States they were in no way ever
used to support Hamas from day one under
our law under our sanctions uh going
back many years it's always had the uh
the right to use those funds for
humanitarian purposes for food for
medicine equipment those beacons of
humanitarianism EAS
but under the close supervision of the
US Treasury
Department any no it's important it's
important to get these facts right
what's going on not a single scent has
been spent from that account when any
money is spent from that account it can
only be used for medical supplies for
food for medicine and those who are
saying otherwise are either misinformed
or misinforming and it's wrong either
way well it turns out they have another
account oh that account well we don't
know what they do with Ally yeah h so
again Iran h100 million a year to Hamas
we just went through that okay $100
million a year to Hamas and the United
States what well they just unro $6
billion in Iranian funds here's the
truth just to be clear just the the
truth United States has no oversight
into how the money they have no way of
possibly knowing you would have to you
would have to sort of follow or agree
with these premises first off that uh
Iran is actually doing humanitarian work
and then that uh Iran is telling the
truth and they tell when they tell you
what they're doing with said
humanitarian a uh and then that you also
have the appropriate transparent access
to how the funding is being used every
other resource we have aside from
talking pieces from this Administration
says the opposite of that yeah well I
mean we should be able to trust Iran I
mean with their nuclear Pro I'm sorry
I'm sorry uh civil energy program that
we've been able to kind of curtail by
giving them cash and and make you know
sending in investigators of course these
guys are going to keep their word but
even if they didn't you know portray
themselves as a trust worthy Nation you
can just move funds around we made this
argument with Planned Parenthood with
we're said okay no money is going to
abortions yes but all of the money that
you're giving them is going to fund the
other part of their business so that
frees up all of the money they were
spending by the way there is no other
part of exactly there is no other part
but they never performed one mamogram
ever this they are like the Planned
Parenthood of terrorism what what we're
going to give you money for food and
Medicine terrorism no no food and
Medicine well food and medicine for the
soldiers that are in Hamas I me they got
to pay the docks they got to they got to
get
and and that so it frees up money there
oh I forgot JD that you never made a
[Music]
mistake in case you forgotten by the way
former president Barack Obama did
provide the Iranians as well with $ 1.7
billion in funds uh in 2016 all in cash
myw it over that was weird to me they
were flying over actual cash like don't
understand yeah it felt like Naros yes
unless it's just like a bag that opens
up and it's you know like it's blue ink
or like bacon grease it's like it
touched me bacon grease yeah that would
just ruin their day yeah it would ruin
their day and their afterlife yes oh it
would you definitely want it to sting in
the
afterlife so now he get 72
instead by the way it's actually even
completely possible that these funds
were used specifically by Hamas to
purchase the infamous parag gliders that
you just saw uh in which they wrote in I
think I don't know if we the overlay
from the Hindustan Hindustan times I I
don't know how legitimate it is but it's
just anyway we do have and I warn you um
you know there's nothing uh super
graphic but if you are uh Squamish we do
have exclusive audio actually they do
have often they record it's like a black
box but for terrorist emaciated
terrorist uh
paragliders uh and we do have set audio
from one of those okay yeah Brown boxes
major Rashid to ground
Hamas ground Hamas to Major
hashid take your F and put your face
mask on that's on that's on I think I'm
going the wrong way I just Mo over the
border and uh oh don't worry just keep
going you're you're almost there almost
where everyone on the ground is looking
at me they seem they seem mad you're
fine you're fine uh you have all the
supplies yes supplies for what check
your storage compartment okay I could
put guns and grenades what are you doing
son this is my first solo flight the W
alone good when you land you will know
what to do land I cannot land here oh my
I won't have enough gas to get back
you're killing me Hassan you will have
to do the killing I don't like jokes at
the time like this you can no I have the
carpal tunnel did you go see aiz I told
you to go see aiz he would fix you up I
went I saw aiz I still have the carpal
tunnel now you're lying if you had gone
to see aiz you wouldn't have the carpal
tunnel anymore okay I'm not good wait
did you pack me a lunch is this turkey
aan you know I hate turkey oh no that's
my lunch turn back around bring it back
to me are you are you you want me to
turn around wait I think I see a Dairy
Queen what's the one with the preure the
burgers not just the ice cream it's a
full Dairy Queen they have Dairy Queen
you told me they didn't have Dairy Queen
only only blood of Innocence I didn't
know they had Dairy Queen well they have
a Dairy Queen with braer Burgers bring
me back a blizzard I hope they turn
upside down oh jeez look the point is
terrorists are people too yeah the good
news is he was massacred by Israeli
women oh good yeah it has end before he
got to Dairy Queen before he got to Der
que I don't think yeah exactly he never
got us Dairy Queen never got us blizzard
they never turned it upside down I don't
know about you but I always they'll have
like a small moment of panic when they
do that yeah well over no
no worked
again I do it in 20 minutes jerks yeah
when it's a puddle in the back seat yeah
they know what you about to say I kind
of I just I don't know I imagining
suicide
gliders yeah they just they just
self-destruct right in the air like what
is that what is that fireworks
enjoy in case you didn't know the $6
billion dollar while we're talking about
you know what's been unfrozen um to Iran
another thing they say is well you know
no I was supposed to go to humanitarian
Aid okay the funds were under the
oversight of the uh qataris you know
remember where clock boy went yeah yeah
yeah yeah um Hamas leadership is
headquartered in where guess it guess it
guar oh okay yeah here's actually uh so
stupid celebrating the attack from a
hotel in
Doha
who's the little person on the right
that's like the Kari Wang
W he doesn't even need to get on his
knees it's a shorter trip he's doing it
onway he he's facing south yeah wrong
way wrong way
fellas do we we don't have the Muslim
call to prayer s we remember we used to
face me we used to do that really
regularly we should bring it back yeah
um contrast that with how again
president Donald Trump handled Iran
Trump uh heavily sanctioned Iran right
they killed Solan that was a big one and
um he basically terminated the Iran deal
just to be clear again this is a
question I have do you really think
we're better off are we past the point
now where even the detractors have to
say all right internationally it's been
it's been a lot worse it's been a lot
worse now right now this is breaking
news Israeli air strikes Target refugee
camps and again just to let you know
they warned them beforehand by the way
do you think they're actually targeting
refugee camps I don't think they're
actually ref I mean camps that are only
filled with refugees women and children
do you think that Israel is targeting
women and children in refugee camps or
or perhaps because we know Hamas and we
know what they tend to do they're
targeting militants who are using
refugee camps as cover oh I just got U
sorry they just handed me a note here on
my iPad it turns out actually the
refugee camp uh right now in question
was the headquarters for hang Glides are
us right what that's like the
when you see that video you're like wait
that guy's that guy's a leader of Hamas
he's just is no one going to at least
punch him in the
[Music]
face would be reasonable and here's
another claim that they're trying to
recirculate right now because this does
relate to this right they're trying to
now Gaslight you and say that actually
remember the withdrawal from people are
going to try draw parallels to
Afghanistan and there might be
connections here but no the Afghanistan
withdrawal was actually don't believe
your lying eyes and ears was handled
quite well 90% of Americans in
Afghanistan who wanted to leave were
able to
leave and for those remaining Americans
there is no deadline we remain committed
to get them out if they want to come out
oh there's that key little leeway like
if they want to like there's some
American like I think I'm going to catch
I'm going to soak up some rays before I
yeah I don't know I like the I like the
terrain yeah I see all the talibani
things yes that that I can by the way
there's like 90% of America this is one
of those things that if you don't get
100% you just don't quote the line like
just leave it out of the speech it's a
pass or fail test yeah it really is it's
kind of binary 90% you know who it
matters to Joe the 10% yeah that's who
it matters to
yeah all right just brings us to the
truth okay uh that the bot withdrawal
from Afghanistan it actually how do we
know that it emboldened Hamas I you're
going to say that's a claim that you're
making yeah yeah well after because
Hamas said so okay Hamas said so proof
right there they congratulated the
Taliban after Afghanistan saying
congratulates the congratulates wait
wait hold a this quote from the article
says it congratulates oh congratulates
the Afghan oh say then I have a quote
later The Afghani Muslim Nation for the
downfall of the American occupation in
all Afghani territory they said this is
a lesson for all oppressed people when
will they learn the morel of this story
yeah oh wait I thought I thought you
were talking about your women
yeah for a second there oh Oh you mean
oppress people all you men there who
oppress everybody uh in your territory
um I'm just a little murky on the rule
book Sunday the uh house Foreign Affairs
committee chairman Michael McCall warned
that the Taliban may join the fight in
Israel oh good yeah I don't know where
would they get weapons or the cash or
military equipment to effective yeah I
don't know how far a couple billion goes
don't they B inflation I'm not sure on
my geography but Afghanistan and Iran
are pretty got to feed the
camels yeah long way don't they have in
a patchy or two well they crashed one
they crashed crashed one so they can't
fly them you got to figure it out guys
you know yeah they're not allowed to
drink but uh don't smoke Opium and fly
to be yeah to be fair they're not going
to be very useful they're just going to
be high in the fields yeah just going to
fly over and that's about it look ma
no at least that's how I hope it ended
yes no virgins for you yeah and the
airbags again it would just be a bacon
grease if I had it's on
me why does it taste so good I don't
know it burns so good they were right so
uh this is actually from the New York
Post I've seen indication that the
Taliban wants to come to liberate
Jerusalem in their words to fight the
zionists ah now it looks like they may
have used some of the 80 billion doll uh
in weapons that was left behind in
Afghanistan as we kind of uh parsed
through this so
this is not confirmation I want to be
clear but typically speaking when you
look at these picture Osama Bin Laden
right the iconic and AKs right AKs is
usually what they would use if even if
you go back to Desert Storm right when
you're talking about you're talking
about AK-47s these are kind of weapons
that they would typically have access to
and also honestly would make more sense
for them given the fact that um these
people are horrible soldiers and so they
need something that isn't as precise but
is a little bit more forgiving you know
can be thrown the same can get dirty
yeah it can get dirty you know you just
aim it in the general direction of
infidels and you know see you see what
happens but in this video of Hamas
celebrating um notably the child um and
other terrorists they appeared to be
holding American style it doesn't mean
that it was manufactured here but again
understanding what happened in
Afghanistan understanding hamas's
connection celebrating and understanding
the money that's been used these
American style m4s not the typical AK
being held in the clip does raise
suspicions got a scope on it yeah it's
an Acog
no is that American I don't I'm just
saying it's an M it's you know that
couple there are m4s are not AKs and you
don't see them very like what is that
Loop hold I am a that's trash Red Dot
from
China they got they got those mfor from
teu
yes they're just Airsoft you have no
idea they lie about everything and what
do you mean by that I mean Islamic
terrorist now just to be clear when it
was politically expedient and former
Vice President Biden was attacking
George W bush he he actually warned us
mhm if we withdrew from Afghanistan now
and by the way this was while the
withdrawal was was taking place under
the Bush Administration and not the
absolute disaster that Biden took part
in specifically signed off on
specifically Biden when he was trying to
trash George W bush and trying to
withdraw his troops said that if you
leave weapons behind said something like
this could happen these weapons or some
capabilities could get in the hands of
what terrorists our enemies 2007 it's
tomorrow the order goes out from the I'm
president the United States I issue an
order end the war today begin to
withdraw all American troops it will
take a year to get the American troops
out do you hear me now that's the truth
it will take a year to get them
physically out now if you leave all the
equipment behind you might be able to do
it in s
months and you leave those billions of
dollars of weapons behind I promise
they're going to be used against your
grandchild and mine someday yeah sh the
one I sniff seems like he was right yeah
huh he was saying that wrong that was
his instruction manual he was reciting
yeah if I just ah note to self leave all
weapons behind sir you meant that as a
Bad Thing F you said it as a bad thing
on a campaign well come on you're
confusing me no no sir that is just the
transcrip I'm going to go touch your
legs oh they're so soft has to do
some
isometrics by the way hit like if you'd
like to see uh former Vice President
Biden investigated for the Afghanistan I
think that one warrants some
investigating right I think when you see
some terrorists you know in apache's
Gone Wild it's like
ah yeah that seems like we can all agree
either a horrible mistake or it wasn't a
mistake just spend some money to bring
the stuff home they're like well it
would cost more it's being used against
people right now if it's not in Israel
it's somewhere else what are you
thinking is going to happen with these
weapons that's the currency yeah so this
brings us to I think the conclus this is
where we'll have a little bit more of a
discussion I want hopefully guys let me
know if that's helpful for you again um
if you're watching on YouTube Rumble hit
the like button comment sometimes these
things require a little more context
historically and what's happening
geopolitically I don't always like doing
that but you know yeah you had a few
things in there um does this matter
though is a question that a lot of
people are asking and this is where we
get to there can be uh differing
opinions that right are not anti-semitic
in other words you can say the killing
the taking of innocent lives what is
going on and the history of Hamas and
the American uh involvement with these
complicit governments across the world
okay you can acknowledge all those
things and have different answers I want
to be very clear about that because this
is one issue where for some reason the
conservative movement people just try
and use it as a litness test when it
really shouldn't be right um because
it's one of the few issues where I think
it's probably the least effective litmus
test for example are you pro life right
now okay that's important do you believe
[Music]
in
probably not I think that's a I don't
think the idea of how we control the
money now in relation to the Middle East
is one that uh is is is black and white
so does this affect the United States
should the United States support Israel
um let me give you the answers as far as
and then we'll go to and you know maybe
we'll just talk about this more on mukb
today the answers as to why it might be
yes um and it's not only because you
know Israel is just uh the only
democracy there really as far as there's
a b that's that's an answer that a lot
of people give the only democracy and we
have that it's like okay because then
you also get a lot of people going like
yeah sure but they also have their own
drag queen you know shows and like
that's not necessarily the kind of
democracy that you want so so there are
two sides to that so let me give you
reason number one here
okay American citizens were killed and
taken hostage in this particular
Invasion at least
nine were killed killed Le Tak hostage
yeah we don't have that number we know
that there are over 200,000 duel
citizens living in Israel so that's
reason number one as far as with this
conflict reason number two um Israel is
an extremely important counterweight to
uh terrorism in that region okay uh mad
is is key in Sharing intelligence with
the United States right we rely on them
for and by the way I'm not saying that
mad is is you know that these people are
angels either just to be clear but it is
important because a lot of these people
do want to wipe out the large Stan in
the United States and having some kind
of a landing space there you could argue
as necessary for our own National um
security interests yeah uh another thing
another reason uh I guess number three
is that Israel is crucial for containing
Iran and that is possibly the biggest
threat out there as far as radical
terrorism to the modern world we often
don't think that that's the case because
in the 70s some of their women could
wear one pieces which was nice yeah
Persian women are beautiful and then
they got rid of the Sha they did you
know they screwed up we all make
mistakes so Israel has carried out
multiple strikes on Iran's nuclear
program just to be clear they
assassinated actually Iran's uh top
nuclear scientists I believe it was in
and really this the whole region on
outside of Israel I mean if God were to
give the Earth an enema he'd stick the
hose in that area of the world
um they know how important it is to
contain Iran okay Donald Trump LED two
uh Abraham Accords just to be clear that
happened under his administration yeah
and I do think that there's another
solution though while we're discussing
this that could also work here are the
reasons that maybe the United States
should not be funding Israel okay the
United States this uh year I believe it
might be from last year um $69 billion
in foreign aid total total yeah Israel
received $3.3 billion okay let's go
through now here's the thing Israel
receives more money than most other
nations individually and that is true
however when you look at the amount of
money that the United States is giving
to other nations who want to wipe Israel
off the face of the map if we withdrew
all of it they would come out ahead it
would be a net gain so let me give you
some numbers 3.3 billion to Israel Qatar
is really low with only 38,000 but I'm
pretty sure that's because of some money
laundering going on there Egypt I know
what you're saying they're maybe right
now they're not as anti-israel uh as
they used to be but $200 million in aid
plus $1.3 billion in military assistance
Lebanon $610 million Syria $830 million
Yemen 1.4 billion Afghanistan 1.4
billion Iran 6.6 billion what plus the
1.7 billion under Obama so you're
talking about several multiples of what
we give Israel to all of these other
countries and I do believe if we were to
say look this is something that has
gotten out of hand and unfortunately we
thought that the enemy of my enemy is my
friend we're going to pull back all
money now we're giving it to none of you
so that Israel has a Fighting Chance
because you are propped up all of you by
us and we're not going to prop anyone up
I think that's a valid position to hold
now it'll get to some interesting
geopolitical issues uh but I've heard
that communicated I believe it's
somewhat similar to what Rand Paul has
communicated at the very least it would
allow us to scale everything back and
then say okay who are the good actors
and who are The Bad actors and then
going forward terrorist government you
get nothing oh terrorist act you get
nothing even if you if if you have
people cheering in your government over
terrorist actions you get nothing though
we'd have to get rid of the squad from
our own government true and then we
could build back up who we would be
willing to have an alliance with so two
different scenar now it doesn't mean
that military aid shouldn't be or
military intervention for our own people
in the United States I absolutely
believe that that would be appropriate
if there are hostages who are still
actively uh being you know being taken
host if they are still still active
American hostages there I don't know if
the term is active hostages they're not
very active yeah kind of they don't get
that much space no maybe they're running
them around and yeah exactly could be
like free range little training yeah
they're like I always want to see what
an American looks like when they run
yeah exactly oh it's much faster than us
wow turns out that our nutrition chart
is not correct hopefully they don't send
more of these guys over here I should
not have drank from the Dead
[Laughter]
Sea uh salty so where do you line up on
that where to what level or if at all do
you think there should be American
involvement with Israel I think that's
an important discussion to have and I
think it's also not just uh important
but imperative that you
recognize how relevant it is that the
United States is giving billions of
dollars collectively to Syria Yemen
Afghanistan Iran right Lebanon Egypt
Egypt yeah that's one thing that a lot
of people who support Israel don't don't
really talk about do what do we do what
what do we do with that and I don't
necessarily have the answer I want to be
clear with you but I do think a good
starting off point is taking some money
off the table from at least a lot of
these countries what do you think no I
absolutely agree I think that's probably
a wise strategy I don't know that I
would I would take money away from
Israel though I understand the point
that even if you did it would be a net
gain if you just stopped funding any of
those guys all of them right um I get it
but it does cause some problems with
okay well if Israel does need money who
do they then turn to do they do they
have to go to China or something like
that I think Ginger Snap was making that
point earlier that it could turn into
something a little bit deeper I do think
from a Christian perspective though um
that we we we have to also make a
delineation right so I think it was
really good to say look you can be for
Israel and say they do some bad things
for example if it turns out that they
bombed a refugee camp knowing that it
was a refugee camp and just wanted to
inflict pain that would be equally evil
right and I would be willing to say so
no matter who does it I'm just saying
that I've seen this Playbook before from
Hamas where they stage these kind kinds
of things to get sympathy on the world
stage so I I understand that but as a
Christian it is impossible to be a
Christian and to be anti-semitic it just
means that you haven't read your Bible
it shows that you have no understanding
of what's going on in Scripture that
does not mean though that you have to
support everything that the Israeli
government does yeah it just means like
the promise is there I will bless those
who bless you and curse those who curse
you and of course we're called to pray
for Israel we're called to pray for the
Peace of Jerusalem we're called to be
active as Christians there and if you do
that and then go but I don't like this
that's fine it's fine to not like that
but you can't be like well Christians
replace Jews because that's stupid and I
look I'll get into this if you guys want
me to do a Friday show on apologetics
and talk about this and how this all
relates to end times and everything else
that's going on here I'll absolutely do
it from a Christian perspective because
I've seen tons of people out there going
we should stay out of this they're not
really Jews anyway really yeah or the
Christian the Christians replace them it
doesn't matter anyway really you haven't
read your Bible and look I'm not trying
to be mean a lot of people that are out
there pushing those theories have read
their Bible they know they're wrong but
they just want to kind of cloak their
hatred of Jews in something that feels
nice and warm to them and I'm not going
to let them do it yeah and that has and
by the way that has like we said nothing
to do with non-interventionist
approaches right that does not mean that
you hate Jews people who say they're not
Jews no no no yeah you could be like hey
I just don't want to go to war and
that's not anti and you know what I will
say this and we'll discuss it more is
there something breaking there now it
just says they're going to start their
ground Invasion here uh pretty soon I
guess a tweet coming out Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu has told Joe
Biden former vice president he calls him
the wrong title he calls him president
you know what we'll make Isel has no
pull it
back Israel has no choice but to launch
a ground operation in Gaza and this is
the quote we have to go in we can't
negotiate now we need to restore
deterrence net Yahoo has said so anyway
yeah there's a lot I will say this
absolutely no deescalation no that's one
of those stupid things we're going to D
no no no no no no no no that's not going
to happen Israel has the right to not do
that right now um I will also say uh
this for example when it comes to Iran
or um you know the Lebanese if what's
happening right now is true definitely
side with the Jews in their territory
definitely side with the Iranians and
Lebanese when it comes to food now that
doesn't make me
anti-semitic I'm just not a huge fan of
the Jew food it's not the best it's not
the
best I mean yeah there was a whole
there's a lot of food
it's just so St people like you don't
like this thing about like no no no no
no that's the let's be honest about this
and let me tell you one other thing I do
think this is a valid concern or
suspicion right now not a lamb that uh
no that's that's more the Middle Eastern
I mean they have lamb in the I mean the
Lamb's blood in the
doorways firstborn it's old they do have
lamb in Israel they do have lamb in
Israel I'm sure they do it's a
birthplace of wine too they do little
known fact they do but I will say this
considering how unbelievable the
intelligence is out of Israel and they
have the Iron Dome which by the way uh I
don't know if you guys know this but
that basically was an offshoot of the
missile defense system which they called
the Star Wars system to try and mock
Ronald Reagan which sounded cool by the
way like that's awesome which is what
they use to try and mock him and that
turns out to be um at least part of the
basis of the technology for the Iron
Dome in Israel which is pretty effective
they can fire missiles out of the air
Iron Dome what is the Iron Dome I'm
sorry it's where they can actually they
can actually destroy missiles midair oh
it's a missile defense system a missile
defense system they shoot them down they
shoot him down Oh that's oh there's a
picture there yeah oh that's really cool
so it's like the guy on the other side
thinks he's going to Battleship and it's
like upsies fingers crossed my mom and
it's just gone and that's just really
nice and demoralizing you know before
[Music]
you I do think it's a valid concern to
say that their Intel is so good from
Israel that they can fire down missiles
at will and often it's very very rare
that they are not aware of these attacks
and then when they fortnite hang glide
in that something like this happened and
went completely undetected for which
they were completely unprepared uh some
people out there and I'm not saying this
is correct or saying okay their biggest
hurdle that Israel has to overcome and
by the way this is a hurdle and it is
one that I think is legitimate I hate
the UN is very often Optics with the
International Community yeah and if you
look at what's happening today the media
has been at least for about 24 hours
overwhelmingly in support of Israel
considering the gravity of the attack
some people are saying hey you wonder if
maybe the gold keeper let one or two
through because of how great we know
their intelligence is and how uh
rudimentary this attack was not saying
that I agree with that but I understand
the question how was this missed
considering that Israel has the best
Intel in the world and I think you're
right the question does have to be
answered the conspiracy theories that
are kind of about on this one get a
little crazy for yeah lot most just to
be clear the conspiracy theories are
illegitimate but it is a question that
certainly go this is atypical for Israel
yeah and they'll have to figure this out
either they either have to figure it out
or they'll have to come up with a
convenient excuse as to why they did
this because if they did let people in
they're going to have to come up with
some reason to justify it to the public
because we're asking it pretty much
right out of the gate like you guys are
fantastic at this you have walls like
every everything was set up to make sure
that something like this could not
happen and it did happen so you're going
to have to answer that question my my
only problem with this and I think we'll
see the tide turn we always do right the
get a little exactly they get a little
bit and then the rest of the world you
just saw the UN calling for hold on a
second wait a second it's like getting
it's like I just got punched and raped
and now we're about to flip the switch
on the rapist and you go no no no no no
give peace a chance how about give
you a chance how about that if I'm an
Israeli right now I go no no oh oh truce
you meant to say Tru is what you
were looking to say right you come on
sorry my Twitter is down I can't
necessarily hear you right now I'm too
busy kicking the crap out of khabib that
attacked us yes exactly sorry pardon my
language but that's what bothers me
about the UN it's like you know again if
we're going to be non-interventionists
then the UN certainly has no business
after the deadliest attack in half a
century calling for a truce if the
however many dicks in the world it
wouldn't
be the UN is a useless organization I
want the United States to have nothing
to do with it and NATO is getting pretty
damn close to that but if you bring back
that tweet that's the thing that people
Miss because it sounds nice Give Peace a
chance sort of like John Lenard imagine
no possessions really how many
rolls-royces do you have in the garage
at your upper west side apartment
between beatings of your son prick
imagine imagine all the people hold on a
second it only takes one person who
doesn't want a truce it clearly not only
one bad actor Hamas but Iran clearly
doesn't want a truce right yes truce
please truce yes it's like no no you're
going to take a little bit of punishment
here and look I don't I I don't want
this I really don't but they do they do
and they've proven that over and over
and over again so what is Israel
supposed to do just sit there and take
it and go all right we'll do a little
bit of a counter offensive and you're
going to say oh they do this all the
time fine I understand it they haven't
declared war since I think 1973
officially they just did they're done
with this well let me ask you this
what's the win scenario for Israel as
far as Optics internationally and this
is one thing that always really pisses
me think about it for a second okay so
they launch from so you say but they
were only doing it because they're
oppressed it's an open air prison by the
way if it is and there's some truth to
that that there really is no way in and
out of the god a strip aside from one
Border in Israel but then Egypt is also
like screw you we don't want to take you
guys
no want to talk about EGP but let's say
that that's true okay it's an open a
prison all right let's say that there
are violations of human rights I'll give
you I'll grant you that after what just
happened
yesterday is Israel give it up like
they've done before give up the Gaza
Strip you think there will be peace for
crying out loud how many times have we
seen examples of them tunneling into
Israel to try and lay bombs underneath
exactly again citizen locations not
military targets so what is Israel so a
truce means what because even if Israel
has a ceasefire right now on a truce
guess what these people are still in
Gaza the terrorists are still running
that area and they're still going to try
and attack Israel so the only way that
you could have a truce according to the
UN meaning all guns down ceasefire okay
would be if Israel puts down all of
their weapons puts down all their
defense systems because again you see
Hamas saying the very fact that you have
a missile defense system the Iron Dome
is a threat to us and Israel would have
to give up all of this land and you
would have to believe that if Israel did
that tomorrow Hamas would say we were
wrong about the eradication of Jews what
do they do they can't just give the god
a strip and they can't just put down
their
guns I think the
logically and answer below what do they
do I understand that there you know some
some children some sons are paying for
the sins of the father right some kid
was born there in Gaza has nothing to do
with it I get it but there's also some
kid who's born next to ga next to Gaza
in Israel who has nothing to do with it
who has to in his school ground at least
several times per semester go into a
hiding place while the Iron Dome does
its work I think the only thing that
Israel can do at
[Music]
this on anyone who would even allow the
thought to cross his mind of sending
some money to those evil pricks I think
that's the only that we can do right now
if you want to have some kind of a
truce hey truce with Hitler remember
that remember
Chamberlain it took it took someone like
a church say no absolutely not what what
truth can take place right now warmonger
Church warong yeah warong warmonger I
can't believe you want war no I'm
responding to somebody actually starting
a war against me yeah you can't
[Music]
negotiate
com to international human rights I'm a
little bit murky on the rule book I
understand why you may not like the
United States being involved with what's
going on in the Middle East period
because guess what that whole area of
the world has never gotten it right but
here we are right now women and children
kidnapped including Americans raped
tortured by Design targeting women and
children not a military conflict with
bleed over and un says truce this
morning you just see it all
right how do you have a truce if you
don't execute every single last
terrorist who is dead set against it
genuinely if you have a solution I and
I'm someone we talk about Ukraine and
Russia we' I think that the war in the
Middle East largely we look back Iraq a
lot of that was pointless M but again
the same reason it's pointless is
because of the ideology these are not
places that want democracy these are not
places that want peace these are not
places where you can export what you
once viewed as the ideology or democracy
of The Shining city of shining city on a
hill America you cannot do that with
people who in their Charter imagine this
imagine before the next election you
know uh before you get your mail in
ballot you know unrequested as all of
you
will you get some brochures get some
brochures from the RNC from the
DNC whatever the green party who cares
and the DNC or the RNC they hand you the
brochure and you go okay so hold on a
second I see okay so you want more
social programs all right okay wa wait
hold on a second the eradicate of all
Jews at what point is it a piece of
in the punch bow like One Bad Apple
don't spoil the bunch uh one bad idea
like that if it's the extermination of
all Jews as part of the basis of your
government is to me we're not talking
about One Bad Apple we're talking about
apples surrounded by an ideology of
that you can't just wipe off on your
shirt you tell me how there is a truce
let's just look at this realistically
and I don't think that people saying ah
yeah you know what sometimes sometimes
in the world even if you're a complete
isolationist which I'm not but I'm
generally non-interventionist sometimes
in the world there is going to be
conflict there is going to be War I
cannot imagine a time where that would
ring more true than in the hearts and
minds of all Israelis today regardless
of where you line up on American policy
maybe we can talk about this more on M
we have hate symbol or not you know
we'll go to chat you guys let us know if
you want to play hate symbol or not
because that's fun I get a little worked
up because you know what should a lot of
Jews been kidnapped and killed and when
you see innocent women and children they
don't have to be Jewish they can be
Gentile of course my point is the
sodomizing of women and children against
their will tends to be something that
rubs me the wrong way but that's me Mr
traditional if you're watching on
YouTube you should head on over to
rumble anyway but on Rumble you click
that button you can sign up and join mug
Club Josh where the hell are you going
to be here doing your show before we go
messy Jess I remember the name messy
Jess and Jews are
welcome just don't bring that gelatinous
fish that you keep in a jar next to the
pudding I know he's going to gag thank
you very much Rumble YouTube piss
[Applause]
off